to Alex Gordon he is an engineer but he
also been a professional photographer
you could tell you I give rabbit hands
all the physics behind it and cooled and
so I'm going to turn it off Alex I
promise to bore you all to death with
physics it'll be great I promise so like
Kristen mentioned I currently work as an
engineer I build robotic boats right now
which is all kinds of fun but I used to
build cameras and take pictures in a
former life it's okay you guys can all
have two careers to this is what I do i
play with sunken ships and now I build
them it's great it's good times so also
for cameras helicopters are really
useful if you ever want to take cool
pictures you should go out and ask your
parents for one so this is actually a
camera i built and that shot the picture
on the left and before you all say no
you didn't possibly shoot that picture i
did and i can show you the raw feed from
it so it's actually a really old style
of camera that used to use film how many
of you actually loaded a film camera
awesome wow that's actually more than i
would have expected so film is a thing
we'll get into that in a couple of
slides this was a digital film hybrid
camera so actually the whole front unit
is a film camera and it had a plate and
glass which is what you used to use to
focus the image so before autofocus and
before fixed focus you actually had to
focus a picture which involved moving
pieces of glass around it was super fun
and then the thing at the rear takes a
picture of that so it's a really weird
setup but it also worked and I made it
in my basement so you guys can too
honestly it's kind of fun to go to a
camera store or eBay or Amazon or
wherever and pick up old used large
format camera gear and you can do some
fun stuff with it so this did shoot the
image on the left you see it has a
really sort of odd dreamy quality to it
that was in 2008 but you can do some
interesting stuff most of the Secret
Service will think you have a bomb but
that's okay
so I filled some other cameras as well
you can build time-lapse cameras this is
taking apart GoPros and soldering things
onto them so that microcontrollers
similar to the Raspberry Pi is actually
a lot simpler than the raspberry PI's
could control them and take a picture
every think this was taking a picture
every half an hour something like that
so it actually turned the GoPro on take
a picture then turn it off the gap and
you guys are actually building something
much more sophisticated than that so if
you guys could all do your stuff today
you're way ahead of where I was a couple
of years ago it'll be great so that was
also solar-powered that was fun that was
well as my clicker not working ah there
we go so this shot this will give you a
minute of time lapse that stayed on the
top of the mountain on a project I was
working on for it stayed up there for
like six or eight weeks or something I
only give you a minute of it it worked
out pretty well it's a fun little
project time-lapse are cool when they
actually show something in this case
they're not actually showing very much
but there's one or two of cool shots
where you get a nice sunrise there isn't
that pretty all right we won't bore you
with any further details so cameras and
how they've developed I'm sure there are
further notes on this and this is not an
exhaustive history of cameras so don't
quote me on any of it in fact I might
even be making it up probably am
apparently in 1839 photographs were on
paper that probably had something to do
with chemicals that reacted to light I'm
just guessing but in 1861 they seem to
have gotten it in color now the thing
with both color digital cameras and film
cameras is suddenly you need to capture
three different sets of light and that's
much more key with digital cameras and
you'll see that you need to capture red
green and blue to make color so then
apparently in 1884 they made
photographic film they seemed without a
pretty good run of that for about the
next 125 years 150 years and in 1936
SLRs will get into exactly what slrs do
and how and why in just a second that's
ok instant photography this has anyone
actually shot a Polaroid camera where
you got like a little thing that you
have to shake one cool ok
polaroid used to be a lot more popular
remember I was talking about
large-format cameras before you used to
check how they shot by shooting a
Polaroid and then waiting for the
Polaroid to develop and then putting the
proper large format film which was about
this big into it so your subjects
couldn't really be going anywhere fast
so instant instant photography was a
thing a little bit before my time but it
definitely was a thing I've heard about
it auto focus will get into auto focus
as well people used to actually have to
manually focus their cameras that all
kinds of cool things called split
screens where you could the image would
suddenly snap into focus when you had it
right those were fun you can actually
get them for modern cameras if you want
kodak digital camera so they basically
took a thing it was a nikon f 5 and just
strip the entire thing out and put
electronics in it they were horribly
staggeringly expensive slow and didn't
work all that well and really the only
people who use the morning newspaper
photographers because they needed to get
their images out as fast as possible
they were also about the first ones were
like 1 megapixel maybe not even that
they were horrible and that continued
for a while until like 1998 with modern
DSLRs modern DSLRs are really amazing
what you can get for a couple of hundred
dollars is unbelievable so of 2012 is
the gigapixel camera apparently I'm told
that is a camera that has like 92 lenses
that all shoot at the same time and
creates a gigapixel image if any of you
can tell me what a gigapixel images that
would be great because I don't know but
I can tell you about DSLRs so even have
a few here this looks pretty familiar to
everyone cool great head ahead of the
curve so far this bit two lenses great
let's see if they'll actually couple
together so yes still with me so far and
they make clicky noises fabulous so in
this wonderful diagram which I stole
from the internet the light path goes in
and we get lens elements so if you see
through lenses they have bits of glass
in them we'll get into much more about
how they work and I'm probably making
half of that up anyway
it might just be black magic coming
through it's fine it's not a problem the
aperture so I'll pass around the manual
lens for you and you can see what the
aperture is who can actually oh come on
Lord who can actually tell me what an
aperture is anybody yes please fire away
yes that is an accurate accurate summary
so here I'll pass this around the
aperture ring is on the front you hear a
click look through the lens you'll see a
change please pass it around just don't
lose it awesome so she's exactly right
the aperture controls how much light is
coming through you say why on earth
would you want less light to come
through can anybody tell me please the
back good why wouldn't I just wanted a
scene ly fast shutter speed instead it
would freeze everything nice and you
know you could get exactly the right the
right freeze frame anybody else it is a
you have a correct answer though please
mm-hmm that's true the other one is
depth of field so if I'm shooting
without wide open and you can sort of
see it when you look through the camera
you get a really shallow focus point and
that's great if you're shooting romantic
portraits but if you're not you can
actually stop it down make it smaller
and your focus area will increase so
suddenly I'll get the first three rows
of you guys in focus instead of just one
so apertures are really important then
it comes in and bounces up and then
bounces around five times and out
anybody have a reason why bounces around
five times why don't I just put a mirror
right there and call it a day great I
had to look this one up too so it
bounces around five times because
otherwise it would be upside down and
who wants to look through an image
upside down personally I don't put a lot
of old view cameras you do have to look
at the image upside down because they
don't have any optics to flip it over
it's really easy when you have a
developed film to just do that but you
have to actually focus and compose the
camera upside down these were challenges
I learned when I was building cameras so
the sensor and the shutter are two
different things so you will notice that
the light is not actually going to the
sensor or the shutter right now we'll
get into this in a minute anyway that
whole that whole shebang flips up and
allows like to get to the imager and
then flips down in all the time it takes
to put you to press the button it seems
complicated and honestly it really is
complicated there are many simpler ways
of doing this and the cameras you're
about to build are simpler and thank God
they don't have all these moving parts
to them it's great so we go into parts
of a camera a little bit we've got a
lens we talked about shutters will get
into shutters in a second they're
actually kind of fun flashes batteries
sensors LCDs this looks pretty familiar
to everyone right great lenses this is
fun right come on we're having fun
aren't we excellent good so lenses
here's a lens we can pass it around
don't drop it it's already been dropped
about five times don't do it again it
will beat
happy so we have wide angles and long
long lenses right anybody anybody have
any idea why the lenses have different
sizes in the front please no no that I
see what you're getting at and the
answer is sort of I don't mean to call
you out but it's sort of so this over
here is an eight to 15 lens who can tell
me what a focal like this nobody great
fantastic that's fine nori so focal
length is how wide the lens is eight
millimeters is really really really
shockingly wide like it's like this in
fact that's a fisheye lens it's really
nice little lens but it's hugely wide
and over there we have a 300 millimeter
lens which is about this long costs more
than you all of your first cars will and
shoots focuses somewhere over there to
begin with and you can't really focus
any closer but they're really beautiful
lenses for doing certain things so we've
covered what focal length is between
eight and two hundred but the aperture
is a big thing we talked about the the
aperture and the iris and the lens you
will not be able to see through the lens
even if you look through it I promise
you you'll never get it to focus but
it's a fun try so the big expensive
lenses let a ton of light in and that's
why they're big and expensive seriously
now that is exactly why in terms of
optics as well you'll notice none of
these are eight to two hundred because
you can't actually produce good optics
that do that it is not within the realm
of physics people try and they make
really bad lenses that do like eight to
two hundred and they're about this big
and they're not very good that's okay
your lenses on the raspberry PI's are
moderns of Marvel engineering of you
know what I meant alright so here's a
fun but here's a video so shutters we
talked about shutters briefly right they
let they expose the imager to light and
then stop and they do it in a very
precise timing it's the same thing as
film so we're watching this it 10,000
frames a second and I think someone is
coming to talk about high-speed cameras
which are their own
really awesome things so we'll watch
this again with more narration if that's
okay if you all can tolerate 30 seconds
again so we talked about the mirror
flipping up there goes the mirror this
is in one exposure now we see these are
all different exposure times so let
different amounts of light it and you'll
see that watch the size of the shutter
as it rolls by there we go see one's
much bigger ones much smaller let's much
more light in vs much less light it and
now the mirror is coming back down so
you see how phenomenally fast this
process is and modern DSLRs can do this
on the order of 10 to 14 times a second
which is really cool and sounds like a
machine gun that's ok so the imagers
these are the imagers yeah there we go
safe that's roughly 8 to 10 frames a
second they they go quickly so in film
10 10 frames a second would last you
about three seconds and they actually
invented big high-capacity basically
magazines for stuff like sports
photographers that had 250 shots in them
and you'd have a roll of film that was
about this big and they were horrible
and some cameras got away with out the
mirror snapping up and down by having
something called a split mirror and it
lets some light through and some light
up at the same time so you basically got
a bad image in both places but you
didn't have to flip the mirror up every
time so you could just shoot the film
through like there was no tomorrow
sports photography is hard if you want
to start in photography sports is
probably not place because you need
thousands and thousands of dollars of
equipment don't worry about this is a
ccd I am not the right person to tell
you exactly how they work I'm sure one
of the other people that does this for a
living kin and tells you can tell you
how to make them in your in your
basement which would be really cool but
essentially they convert light photons
to electricity and that then the
computers in the cameras convert that to
a picture and then write it to an SD
card and we go from there so the cameras
you're going to be building like I said
are ma
marvels of modern engineering all of
that lens shutter focus all of that is
built into something that is absolutely
tiny and it costs like $25 it's amazing
and actually all of the image processing
is on board the camera as well and it
sends it over communication bus called
spy which is a standardized
communication bus so it's actually
incredible what these little cameras can
do and know they're never going to shoot
as nicely as the giant piece of glass
that's flying around but they're also on
a chip how many of you use your iphones
over a different camera like a
smartphone instead of an actual camera
most of you don't be shy it's okay to
admit it there you go see so the modern
the the marvels of cell phone technology
have brought us this and that's why you
can buy it for twenty-five or thirty
dollars which is still pretty incredible
and the volume of production for that is
unbelievable there is a fun trick with
that lens if you want if you can hold a
smartphone behind it you might be able
to get the image to focus on the
smartphone camera and shoot some kind of
weirdly distorted and probably upside
down picture it will probably be upside
down because the light is probably
crossing as it goes through to focus
maybe you can do it with a set of
binoculars too actually nope everyone's
welcome to try it in fact i'll pass
around another lens we can do that too
again they're all heavy because they are
really fast lenses here that's another
fun activity go for it just don't drop
that one please i really like that one
if i have to pick one lens that's the
one I go around with right okay in
please you can play with smartphones and
try to get a picture if you desperately
desire all right like I said the
Raspberry Pi cameras are really
stunningly amazing and you can do really
fun stuff with lots and lots of them
because they're so cheap and I think
someone's going to show you how to do
photogrammetric scanning with them which
is really cool but that's about that
concludes cameras who has questions
about any part of that
because we really breezed over like
several hundred years of development and
science in 20 minutes whoo-hoo can't
explain how I shudder works roughly I
clearly didn't do a very good job Oh No
please save me know all right what does
the shutter do please yeah exactly
perfect detector 10 points the
scientific words very good all right
excellent and apertures again yep
perfect all right fabulous I think I'm
gonna hand it back to whoever else is
running the show here because it's
clearly not me and hopefully you have
enjoyed it and hopefully I get all of
the lenses that I passed out back at the
end otherwise I'm gonna sit and cry in
the corner I promise you there will be
tears if anyone does have questions
please fire fire away no yes please that
is a question for the raspberry pi
foundation who's based in the UK and I
honestly don't know no but seriously no
that mean they the raspberry pi
foundation is a nonprofit that makes
raspberry pi and then they started
making the raspberry pi camera and
that's what they do I don't have a
better answer than that unfortunately
anybody else know if you really want in
to get into like boards produced by
nonprofits literally the BBC like the
news organization just came out with a
tiny little arm based linux board which
they're giving away to all
schoolchildren in the UK which is pretty
cool actually when you think about it
better yet they've included tools to
actually do things with it all right
thank you all appreciate it
you